yeah you do it's all good
amateur hour right yeah it's what
happens when all your rainbow succeeds
players that are normally in the office
not saying that you're not one but I'm
just saying of the people I would have
asked I would have asked Aaron Sampson
he's working from home he's got sick
kids unfortunately I'd have asked Mike
my Hardy but he's like on his way back
from Montreal from the vi Invitational
so here we have it
Rainbow six siege the outbreak special
co-op event is live on test servers on
PC so if you want to try it out like I
think it's on Steam where you play and
you can you can download it now it's
like a 50 gig update here let me just go
full game so you guys can see that but
we're gonna try it out
I believe it's three operators and
there's like a bunch of missions to new
yeah to new operators but I think in the
game it's only 3 operators which I find
interesting but won't you hop in there
see what that's about hopefully it works
maybe not where the hell where the hell
is it
yeah I don't know we're gonna find out
is it in tear no she may be that down
there in the bottom corner there you go
hey there we go oh sure this consequence
we're still cool
[Music]
you know just a meteor
this is where rainbows succeed
a brick is currently only on the test
servers which is PC only just FYI the
actual mode comes out March 6th and that
should be across the board
three days later he's still driving oh I
feel like queasy
something in my throat smoking shouldn't
shouldn't have smoked so much
about patient zero wait he's about to go
real bad
I know come for some resident evil
so what do you think you think zombie or
not really because like we were talking
about that earlier if it's like
considered zombie zombie I mean I guess
what to see the behavior Bartlett was
the final situation got no operational
jurisdiction we're not the enemy here
this isn't terrorism they still need us
Sam thermite's
doc
and I need one of the Russians I'll
explain later
the Wrights send them fast before this
all brings down can't participate in the
Olympics but can't participate in
Rainbow six
all right okay cool
all right we're in we put us back
although I feel like we're gonna find
out if middle left's the best spot I can
always move us I guess we can check it
later oh so there's a harder mode is
that what pandemic is yeah that's what
I'm guessing and I'm just gonna real
quick they said doc was on this and I
didn't miss that's what this bro doubts
loadouts on duck so I'm gonna real quick
just do way to go probably don't I don't
need a suppressor all right so yeah just
so you guys know outbreak is available
on PC the test servers if you download
either you know via you play we're
playing off you play or steam it didn't
actually get an update when we backed
out and got back in it just showed up
I've been following kind of the like
Rainbow six siege kind of Twitter as
well as was chasing them up on reddit so
that's how I knew that it was up it got
delayed a little bit today I supposed to
actually be I think eleven a m-- pacific
or actually knows not sorry now is
eleven it's opposed to be 9:00 a.m.
Pacific I'll push back to ten and then
eventually got pushed back to now but it
was better that way so that they could
get it to work also hopefully we have
corporate internet which gives us
problems sometimes with you play and
like certain team games so hopefully we
can make it through the match just want
to throw that out there also it's test
servers so if anything weird happens
that's par for the course I feel like so
throwing that out there too okay so we
got some more options some options all
right all right
what are you going there's a two new
operators lion and finca I'm gonna line
up one of these
no one's trying to select him they're
selected before all right you got it and
elixirs going recruit all right so as
mentioned it's I haven't seen that much
of it other than I knew that it was a
three operator kind of mode curious how
that plays out there's like five enemy
types I believe yeah I think so and the
so I mean it's basically sort of like
siege is doing left 4 dead as I
understand it but sometimes my first
time playing it so ok could be wrong
yeah we have he's a PC player or sorry
he's a console player playing on a PC
because that's where it's at but he's
plugged in a controller so there you go
that's the thing don't want to hear
about it I do don't want to mention warm
up those heyday okay that's true okay he
reminds me of like the one guy we'll see
if he plays the same way hunter with the
long tongue great welcome to the test
servers
all right yeah
whoo his back seems to be the weak spot
there just so you know like you see
where the little orbs are I think
there's gonna be like a witch don't wake
her no guy and the right is way too
quiet
nice seems good for this map and just so
you guys know when this eventually comes
out it's a I think it's like a four week
event some people were like kind of
arguing for like why wouldn't you just
keep it in the whole time
but my guess and I don't know this worth
back cuz I definitely didn't go to the
Invitational to find out or anything
like that and I'd have to I guess
confirm with Oscar who was there and
Mike but I feel like they're gonna try
to start doing that that overwatch kind
of thing where they're gonna have
different types of events now this looks
a little bit heavier as an event than
some of the stuff that overwatch does
but yeah Oh demon got when you take guy
on the right Tanner do you mean that guy
cuz I'll just move is my closer to his
man so yeah thanks everyone for tuning
in
we're live every day a little usually 11
a.m. we're a little late today because
we were waiting for outbreak to trigger
and we were lucky enough for it to kind
of going on the right time there's a
head there's a heavy oh oh so his weak
spots his back it looks like that little
spot on his not gonna draw aggro oh he
punted the crap out of that person okay
Ron Ryan oh you got out of his
juggernaut we all right so yeah you
basically want to start going to draw
and then somebody needs to nail him in
the back crazy that like he's like
they're like we're off the bat oh he's
in a bad spot oh good
[ __ ] Sammy's oh damn bow in my way
buddy oh that was good he might also try
to get him to run into a tree and it
looks like he like killed over will stun
animation there stager
doesn't seem too damaging though okay
nice oh just kidding
take that back you just smacked elixir
across the screen how's it going
punishment 90 saying this is gonna be a
fun event yeah I think so i i'm always
um i'm a big fan of PDE just in general
across the board in games and it's cool
to see some of these multiplayer
shooters incorporate a PvE type mode
that's more cooperative oh you see the
spikes he left in in the wake of his
charge they're blind them blind him Ryan
a flashlight so yeah I'll be monitoring
chat and I will try to answer your
questions to the best of my ability but
I have not played you know outbreak at
all I did see some of our coverage and
gameplay for over the weekend but we're
both pretty fresh and green to this
experience
Ryan's did a pretty good job so far cuz
he hasn't really gotten hit by um I got
to find out the name for you guys
probably but yeah so you're luring him
oh dude this guy's a tank
seriously this oh that's not good oh
he's not dead that's good oh great oh
he's dead finally got cheese nice nice
worth killed the Smasher his name's a
Smasher you got grunts got breachers I
would assume the guys that are exploding
breachers yep nice you got a little
chain kill yeah I'll fill in the
breacher do you know if you get any sort
of renowned reward from Weymouth we'll
find out yeah we'll find out although
you know the PvE stuff generally doesn't
reward a lot of renown like terrorists I
never did so I'm not expecting it isn't
just more of like a have fun thing would
be my guess and I you know I want to
just say
I have a moment to think it seems yeah
just want to say I agree I like how
overwatch does like additional events
and like new ways to play a game I think
that's really exciting as much as this
is like sort of really conceptually
silly for the tactical ring Tom Clancy
yeah well you never know though like you
could argue like what if some of this
stuff was like pre-planned down there
like you know earlier in the development
and then like they're like we got a we
got a really they really focused on
their the multiplayer embedded of
shooting which was great because
obviously it's it's doing well and
resurging you know I remember when the
game launched and I was thinking like
would this storyline doesn't make any
sense like the concept of this game is
not make any sense um and then you know
once I finally got around to playing
through the situations I have to say I
was like okay I get it there's there's
like a crew line of this biohazard thing
that they're playing with is a story it
could very well be that this is all
planned in advance although I don't know
if they plan to be huge success of the
game yeah so just so you guys know
currently free and available on the test
servers I don't know if it's up the
whole month I know it's intermittent and
they're gonna be doing updates along the
way there they're clearly testing it
before the actual launch which is in
less than a month in about two weeks
March the 6th and I think when I saw on
the UI of the homepage when Ryan went to
hit play on this mode it looked like it
had like a one day timer on it and I
don't know if that's just because that's
like what it's gonna be but speculative
guess is maybe it's up for a day for
them to test and mess around and maybe
it comes back again you know hard to say
I definitely follow up with the like you
know with either our news on GameSpot or
maybe Rainbow six is Twitter like
they've been pretty good about
communicating like delays and or like
when things are going to be active so
that's a good way to check it out i
believe the event will be free right
it's just that the like get to ryan to
answer that in a second he's he's
knee-deep in killing infected type yeah
people hated i don't wanna calm zombies
because they're not really zombies you
almost remind me of the metal gear
survived guys got
like diamonds or like the gem type
looking stuff uh so yeah what's up
cheeseburger eater I'm curious to see
how how much depth there is to this
mm-hmm like how many like layers or
levels there are no like one of the
things that I you know going back to the
overwatch example it's like I like how
they do these small events but it is
sometimes frustrating how small it is
yeah I liked the winter like oh you know
oh yeah chasing down Winston yeah it was
really fun just like two more mats yeah
it's it's almost like more of a it's
like the reason or the thing to help you
want apex I have no idea that was a new
one okay it's like the kind of like the
hook to get you to come back like hey
try this out and there's all this other
stuff going on and I mean like there's
still like the PvP aspect of it because
they did introduce two new operators you
know lion and pink all right right so
even in the regular game there's still
something worth coming back to having
these new operators I mean it's always
fun to try out new operators I got
locked out oh yeah go join your team
there are gonna be there were some buggy
stuff though that they did mention that
like could happen to you like if you die
and respawn on your health bar might
look a little different or something
color there's there's a couple things
that they've already stated yeah so
apparently there are explorative
scenarios like for example just to give
you context because you were saying like
I wonder how deep this gets or you know
like how many layers there are so one an
example is like in the hospital you must
escort dr. McIntosh around the veterans
wing of her hospital while Simon Taylor
simultaneously collecting samples
defending jammed doors and escaping the
building alive so here's and then some
variants to that would be I guess on
junkyard
I planted thing we don't have
fortifications up that's yeah it's
unfortunate but on junkyard and resort
for example you have to safeguard
explosives as you attempt to destroy the
visible signs columns of miscellaneous
alien matter of the so-called
infestation so seems like there's
different like maps and it's like
objectives that you have to do based on
your location I don't know where we are
currently I didn't see but it looks like
we're planting something while trying to
defend like the house maybe this is like
their first mode to show off because
it's like similar to what you would do
in a you know normal type setting this
is a it seems like you almost wonder
like was this ability made because of
this mode you read not so much or it's
kind of cool that it works in both right
it works not only in you know your
normal competitive match but it also
works here in the outbreak yeah mode so
what's up angel Molina thank stop him by
thank you everyone for stopping by did
you get you get to play Ella here I did
not see but she got nerfed at least I
don't know if they're firm in terms of
like exactly what they did to them like
blitz got kind of buffed but he's also a
little buggy right now and like how fast
he is apparently whoa disappearance yeah
yeah they might again its test servers
so not shocking if it's not like exact
down a guy huh are you yeah
oh good the explosives are under attack
you must defend them Ryan get them off
I'm working on it I'm working on they're
attracted to the oh boy now you're good
you have any Granada's for that crap
over there
I do good I'm being congratulated hey
man where is your last guy did he just
do sout yeah he did he's like oh my
friends are on now peace that's all
right
there is medkit stuff over there right I
am going to need that yeah there's three
of them so
above the door a breacher this is why
you need a dawkins yeah he is doc though
I believe he switched to dogs yeah
shotgun is probably pretty good for this
Oh what is that see that dancer look at
that I don't say good oh look our buddy
now he wants to kill that Chaman oh we
got smacked what is that that one's new
I don't think I've seen that monster yet
whatever he's shooting yeah oh I think
his stomach is the weak spot by the way
just I like that like kind of like that
destiny ask thing you know looking for
the oh that's fine I mean like if that
is what is what I think it is which is
like the glowy bits are you know where
the weak that's pretty cool I like that
because it kind of forces you to aim for
different things yeah yeah yeah do you
know if this mode is on the console it
will be on console looks like enemies
from prototype tape yeah that's pretty
good assessment there at the cool pixel
that that red enemy can root you and
teleports as dark Sider 23 thank you for
the information I think we're trying to
get rid of that one right now oh good
possibly
oh my god doc run okay you still got a
lot of amyl that's good that thing looks
crazy he's like I don't your puny human
bullets do nothing
well you like ultra fast barricade in
this mode
yeah we're pointing currently on PC
because that's where the test servers
are active oh so that one's the apex I
think so
he's just playing on controller because
that's he plays on console normally as
mentioned most of my PC Rainbow six
siege guys it just don't happen to be
the office today so you got me so we got
Ryan which is still good March 6th is
the actual release date like live live
like across all platforms but for now if
you want to try it out today it's on the
test servers as mentioned when I first
saw it on the main - it was like one day
but don't know like it's gonna be there
hit like here and there as they kind of
update its test servers you know you can
see it says TTS over there on the right
hand side so dark started showing this
thing wants to know what the new
operators do so you have I forget are
you line or I'm line line again lion has
a scan that highlights any character
that is moving so in PvP you can see the
the movement of enemy team for a minute
it's a little bit like a mass version of
jackal
and but if the enemy decides not to move
you won't see them at all yeah
so it's interesting dynamic as you know
if you're playing a proper match of
Rainbow six siege cuz everyone pretty
much this has to stop and it looks like
it's like almost like it's tremoring you
know but not really am I just doing this
stuff way too fast I don't know I wasn't
listening to you activate the crane wait
for the crane okay so you had to
activate the crane oh here we go
I don't know a flashbang oh it worked it
worked he totally got that guy got
stunned I don't know about all the other
guys I don't think he can shoot through
okay okay I couldn't talk it we're
shooting them through the fence or not
my not shooting him they are what are
you doing doc hey man he's got shotgun
you know he's doing work on the front
lines right right even though as the doc
you probably don't want to be
cover me that's interesting that it
hasn't like match-made a third person or
maybe nobody's looking
it might I mean the regular PV does not
match okay once somebody leaves yeah but
this is you know this is my problem with
like long format PvE stuff where if you
lose somebody here I'm just done well
I'm hoping what it does if you enough
yeah I'm hoping what it does if it's
smart enough is that it just optimally
scales difficulty or like how many
zombies or oh no no you don't want to be
in here no that's not good that's fine
you have six health packs thank you and
how about habits and bullets bullets not
health thank you thank you alright
[ __ ] blow up
oh good you got real problems
Sunday's being oh she thought I heard
something that surprisingly doesn't do
as much damage as I thought it would
these guys that explode you would think
like you definitely don't want them like
next to you yeah but it only did like 27
damage oh he's talking it's up elixir oh
yeah as mentioned zombie oh you got it
you got you gotta get help
no we might we might we might be having
problems no why would you try to med
here is he immune doing what happens oh
no no he's down yeah that would get the
Y's normally duck and so res can you hop
off yeah got to do the old left4dead
trick so you run in circles right not
worth good maybe if you just keep going
back and forth you can just take turns
yeah yeah slow that blood loss yeah come
on come on Doc you got this you got this
we good we good I'm holdin on I'm holdin
on I think it'll be fine Oh oh good well
have it oh yeah you're up okay I was
like
reloading what do you say
go get oh you're good on healthy i-75
yeah so you're planning on like bait
almost like a base load out right now
right because oh apex the the thing that
will route you he's done it or faster
flashbang that okay teleport you you're
right or no he didn't he just has
projectiles okay
okay okay all right no problem got a
little hairy there doc did his duty yeah
he sacrificed yeah there was some good
yeah as carbo gaming mentioned it is a
free 4-week
event in starting March 6th right now
it's just on the test servers
it's Ryan he hasn't been ocean remember
forever this is true that's job Joe is
in a while actually correct I think
you're just this is just the beginning
you know was easy uh yellow essentially
saying wonder if the LM view would be
viable in this mode since it's not that
great in PvP possibly you're definitely
shooting a lot of zombo's right sorry I
shouldn't call them zombies because I
don't think they're actually zombies but
just what people you know what a person
like me would gravitate to saying I
think I'll call them the infected I
think that's fair gravitation Ryan's
Mike needs more power I just um
not getting close enough to it
instinctually running away from the
zombo's
no Ryan we're calling them infected
would be great if it was permanent yeah
a lot of people were saying that they're
not happy necessarily with the fact that
it's only four weeks and not like just
like in the game forever but I feel like
it's like just one of those things where
oh good so he knows what's up he knows
what we should be like barricading
probably before we you know make that
last guy yeah yeah I think I understand
the argument like they it does kind of
feel weird to have something like this
cool into this scale like not be
permanent
but no no maybe that's kind of the
allure to it you know it's like get-get
your four weeks of outbreak in yeah
because it's not coming back for like
three months or something you know and
maybe they just iterate on outbreak and
add different stuff down the road or
something then you can try that out you
know yeah it's just how about this how
about it's just cool to have a four week
event - anyways I feel like we on the
internet you know yeah we we on the
Internet
I don't know almost like feel entitled
that like hey you're supposed to be
giving me anymore cuz like I need this
drip feed like now you know give me my
thing give me my rainbow six I deserve
this
now yeah cuz like so many people were
salty about like how this was like late
today and I'm like dude it's free on a
test server like come on they were very
like upfront about saying you know like
hey we're delayed sorry like I took this
day off of work to play outbreak I want
it so you're gonna just protect Charlie
I guess that's over
right now I'd rather not
well what if you have to protect Bravo -
you should have enough confidence in
yourself to you know hold your own
they're probably attacking I'm sure a
little bit more clear or maybe I just
can't hear it I think they should be
saying no I didn't hear them say charlie
they should say which one not like oh
they're just
bill you're like you're almost having
more oh yeah just backseat gaming royal
uses a higher base damage so a headshot
might just take one out more chunk I
said the diet the dead would rise again
this is his payback Oh see I'm even play
Rainbow six siege but apparently Tatanka
is just bad Pechanga is good in a very
small number of circumstances and on a
very small number of maps
I played the junk the last night at one
point just for the hell of it I don't
know if we have the answer but I'll ask
Ryan since he's played more than I have
miss international wonders asking does
this ace place in the VR world the
rimless exceed or does this take place
in the real world look rainbow succeed
isn't it like the real world because
wasn't like ash or whatever like how
dare like this is my jurisdiction real
world
get off my balcony damn there's a lot
outside outside but the good thing you
guys fortified because they clearly
can't get through that other you know
yeah I'm sure one of the other special
infected can get through that uh-oh
charlie
oh no well you can still salvage it
apparently so maybe you were right that
like you should just focus on at least
okay alright alphas gotta be our Bravo's
gotta be your last name your Alamo okay
you got lucky kilos are Impa you just
needed one oh wait you guys he's I kill
the apex I heard him I don't know you
got 50 health just so you know
huh and the ammo situation how about
some ammo sure how about how about ammo
anthill
because I am edible eating yeah you did
the old not hold down all the way which
I do a lot actually
where's the apex there we go from the
business he flash everything you have a
flashbang get behind it oh he don't care
he or she don't care
I'm running oh he went to try to get the
apex I think oh kill the breacher oh he
did he doesn't have self rest by the way
yeah because he got back on so Oh -
you're right yeah yeah yeah I got
alright survived oh he said good job
thank you elixir
you're not toxic like the rest of the
world we are going says if only this was
a permanent mode I would buy the game I
mean I don't know well I guess okay I
can partially see that as a as a reason
only because some people might not get
into the multiplayer mode so they would
like to have more of this as something
that they could play knowing that they
bought the game to be able to play this
like you know what also at the same time
I mean this this game has its roots
deeply said in multiplayer
yeah that said there is you know there
is a PvE thing that does exist that you
can do whenever you want Vinny from
Giant Bomb yeah so see it says one day
33 minutes I don't know if that has
moved down at all but yeah so that's how
you would play it you know the test
servers he does really remind that does
really remind me of evolve for some
reason it's looking apparently the one
who teleports isn't the apex it's
another well that was an apex that we
were fighting great that that one weird
thing I think was yeah okay so I was not
rolling with a vanilla weapon I was just
at the back there right I just didn't
know well so you can go shotgun if you
want tell your something has not put a
scope on it yeah because you know what I
like to I like to see what the irons
look like before I go and etta scopes
and that's just sort of my preferred
method
or anyway hop back into another you
another one yeah maybe play another
character or sorry operator don't come
after me as punk or rock didn't mention
if you do have any comments or concerns
or thoughts about you know what you
wanting this event as a mainstay in in
the Rainbow six siege game you know you
can head on over to the subreddit there
is one for just the test servers that
you can voice your opinions say hey oh
it's that guy we played with integral
just now in the normal mode so this is
the is this the same mission this is the
Sierra veterans wing I don't know we're
gonna find out let me do different you
know alright Oh frags that is fair
ethical pixel the series in itself isn't
deeply rooted multiplayer but this game
is so yeah this game is I'm not saying
that I'm like opposed to more PvE stuff
but the the core ever game a game yet
multiplayer and it's a really great and
you know he left already sweet so we're
doing this doing this with two again
yes toner Raptor he is a console player
and I had to have somebody that's played
Rainbow six siege you know obviously
played because I wouldn't know what the
hell I'm doing
and so he's playing on controller
because that's the platform place I
normally yeah that's right I didn't
really get back in the PC gaming until
late last year and so but I've been
playing this man everyone's going doc
huh they know how good he is necessary
oh really I mean he saved our skin last
time that's true oh so this is a
different scenario that were in now we
had to be
we're at the hospital maybe this is the
one where we had to protect the lady and
kind of guide her around the hospital
and then also collect samples is what I
read in our GameSpot
kind of like feature from Oscar Dyess
days
Oscar days I think who is from our UK
team he was actually at the invitational
this weekend so he got to check out
outbreak play it
write down his thoughts share his
thoughts I'm sure there's gonna be a
video yeah impression piece coming out
we guys will get some more gameplay up
on Sunday yeah they've got a few more
features on the way there was a 20
minute gameplay clip I believe yeah
that's on our site and YouTube as well
right now so if you want to check that
out you can or you can just keep
watching because you know obviously this
is gameplay - Scottie Rafferty earth
Scottie Reverend Scott Rafferty says
this is an awesome map watched it on the
live reveal nice it's very very good I
mean they did a good job on this this is
here
I am not doing quite as well as I did
last time
why not getting used to the weapon no
just give me a weapon not sure actually
I think I took for what the ability was
for this operator oh no worry stone I
didn't take that as AI and figure you
were saying that he was like any type of
a scrub because he plays oh come on
stone as a stone as a one of our
regulars yeah okay all right I deserve
it anyway
I'm scrub playing on on PC with a
gamepad yeah well you just I feel okay
so I have to say after living both
worlds okay because I played destiny
almost exclusively on console for a
longest time I mean I still technically
play mostly on console but I when I
switch to PC I was like oh okay like
yeah I can see why it feels better it's
like as pandemic difficulty that hard
probably is maybe yes maybe the last map
we tried pandemic just to see the shot
just to see we can we can end on a
pandemic difficulty mode and see how
that goes
this is the route to get routed person
okay so it's basically like zombie
barbed wire question a Qbert 480 new
noscope asking what do you think about
the new operators so far so okay you
haven't played as much as you know what
they do because when we were playing
before outbreak launch when we were
playing multiplayer just like it is when
any new operator launches it was
impossible to get done at the elevator
and I have to admit my complete
ignorance as to what this operators
ability is ethyl ethical pixels sending
a chat challenge to win this on hard
mode ok pandemic will try was definitely
give it a go shooting is terrible enough
you're crazy Bob okay it's so much more
precise with
keyboard mouse yeah yeah hey is it
outbreak just outbreak that you guys are
doing are you doing PvP to test out the
new characters against players probably
mainly outbreak it's actually as Ryan
just mentioned or alluded to it's
actually really hard to get the new
operators right now because everyone's
trying to pick them it's not like
overwatch where we can go six
you know fincas or whatever or six lines
like kind of just messing around that
way
so we'll probably primarily be doing
outbreak I think it's kind of the bigger
deal anyways I would feel like not
saying new operators are not a big deal
but from like a viewing perspective you
know if we don't get the new operators
that it's kind of like well you know
you're just kind of watching a Rainbow
six oh I like how a wall were it's a
parkour a little parkour parkour man
this guy is owning it up I mean if if
people want us to check out PvP we can
yeah we can check it out later
potentially but yeah and quick thoughts
on that I mean just the the other
operator lion it's kind of cool because
lion slows down the movement game for
defenders disability pops it outlines
where defenders are if they're moving so
kind of forces a a stand for the
defenders you know roaming is a big part
of siege strategy at this point and this
is an operator that slows that down key
early if you want to play this right now
you'd have to you know hop on Steam or
you play download the test server they I
just popped the ability because it was
used to using the other dude no I want
to see where they are nope so is it
everyone around you that gets their
movement slowed yeah oh yeah okay I know
it's that they're a little bit
converse this game is pretty very
relevant I would say year three is about
to start
they've had a pretty big resurgence with
Rainbow six I feel like and then now
they're you're gonna get this outbreak
mode in a month so a lot of reasons to
play it look at you being a good
teammate yeah not shooting him just cuz
he was there you can't shoot your own
teammates Eric in the PvP mode I'm not
sure about in this one I want to say
that the friendly fire is not on because
I feel like I have accidentally shot
once or family okay it would make sense
that's not on here because like there's
so many you're trying to clears on like
or the infected you know off of you know
your teammates chances are if you're
shooting towards where they are you
probably shoot them to sorry I don't
know you could always test it you just
single tap them where is he well I yo
come Webster's where were the stairs
lion is literally the Marco Polo game
huh it is actually that's a really good
how did download test server kirilee if
you get if you have you play the test
server is like a kind of like a separate
game that you can um like the kind of
like download but I have not seen it on
Steam so I can't tell you for certain
oh sorry you're talking about the person
we got to protect yeah you definitely
can't let her die like the charges I
would assume oh no oh no I wonder if you
can healer
dude this on sand emic would be a
nightmare probably if it's a like a
hostage from PvP then they can be
injured and revived okay
now this this weapon has like no recoil
that's getting weird
what do you mean that's weird you're
playing call of duty yeah I know it's
weird because the description says it's
a 308 and search games but don't see
anything [ __ ] long
I don't know that's weird are you on a
PC Kiera because it has to be PC oh good
oh good telling you man I feel like I
wanted to say this just now but I feel
like shotgun is like the way to go and
this cuz like we haven't really fought
anything arranged you know what I mean
but then again you can only kill one one
or two people at a time depending on see
ducks down oh very good on it hopefully
he gives you cover while you do this oh
yeah she's fine you're not so fine
another 25 health fifteen one Sabres
health yeah right in front of you next
to her yeah I'll just do it just stole
it up or maybe use her as bait I mean if
she can't die she can just be you know
this mode will be for free
death draw on March the 6th or as
mentioned you can do it you got a skirt
by the way yeah I get any both - oh yeah
how about ammo and bone ition March the
6 is when it comes out of should be for
everyone oh you got a grabber I feel
like I should grab her because I'm not
as good hey hey buddy
I know you can't hear us but put down
the hostage oh god that's a bad time
don't you wish you were lying right now
so you could do your math Hackett bill
yeah I know
Oh friendly fire apparently is on in
pandemic oh that makes that makes sense
actually Thank You Zachary T that sounds
awful like that that's so true do you
think so
sure of course so I guess you should
never be in a scenario where it's so bad
that the zombies are on you and
therefore oh these are getting real oh
yeah I got this I think that was a late
throw maybe you can bait them and fall
through the window yeah see you talking
about pace out the strategy here is to
avoid the giant monster I think for now
oh [ __ ] that's a dead end
oh we this is not a good movie to be in
bud all right looking ok
okay I think you know I'm gonna bet
please yeah as long as that guy doesn't
see or hear you oh he got her okay he
got her to where she needed to be and
now you gotta protect her from this guy
the old switcheroo there oh yeah yeah I
guess you gotta kill that guy yeah yeah
this guy knows what's up he's like let
me go through this window we went around
okay good okay nope yeah you got to get
him away from her though Oh tables do
not matter here okay
I have a health problem yeah is there
health anywhere oh yeah
Thank You doc so doc is definitely a
must-have I was so good at avoiding this
thing while you were out in the open
whereas now you're kind of in no those
quarters oh yeah well you did say like I
should probably the one carrying the
doctor yeah there's also a bunch of
updates to like the actual like other
operators like Ella got nerfed things
like that no no friendly fire is only on
during hard mode so you won't see it
here because we're just playing normal
but yeah that's a thing oh yes dirty
spot he's evolving he does look very
evolved he doesn't he yeah oh she's he's
on the doctor they yeah draw him away oh
he's doing through the window
look at that Jason oh that happens I
told you about corporate internet now
that guy's like well what do I do now
I think well it's harder with that guy
do you want to try pandemic
see how that goes oh that's all right
a man why not give it a go is this Panda
yeah alright we're trying pandemic mode
sorry we got we got booted there yeah
booted good luck to us oh what's up can
we meet him you know please
yeah sorry man that's my people
sorry Will Smith sort of someone
tick-tock that's smart
well smoke action remember team fires on
now all right yeah I just realized that
half of those are the operators I didn't
change the load out on before I started
this is the one we did first time kind
of looks like it
is looks like it right yes there - maybe
well that we know of it plays the Lord
says man Kuwait maybe yeah maybe not on
hardmode we're currently attempting to
play pandemic we'll see how this goes
how about not there we go
you think they actually get triggered by
that though I don't know it's just a
lift for dead instinct fair is fair
I mean you can turn the light off which
makes me think you can I mean there's a
reason
uh yeah kara that was another discussion
of like why there's only three per map
but I'm sure that's what they figured
balance was good for so you know he's
too good to play maybe you they're not
hurt anybody that guys smoke them Billy
also here's a day over that guy sounded
like a kid how the heck are you playing
right now should be at school oh wait
this is different I don't think you
played this right
I don't recall you doing this part at
the beginning although part of me wasn't
paying attention to this chant remember
am I crazy is this is this the one we
played first time or is this different
it feels it's different or reverse order
this is definitely different so you look
a shocking man doing work dare you to
shoot one of your guys in the back just
kidding don't do that nice yeah yeah
maybe yes that may be a bad maybe at the
very end
oh good
I should be looking at damage to see if
you're taking more think you are up that
guy's no you're rooted just say no yeah
I'm having props so pandemic seems quite
a bit harder yes cure it is separate the
test server is it like it's Alden game
I probably shouldn't rolled with a
pistol I said of SMG yeah why cuz that
thing runs out of ammo in like two
seconds oh oh so that one seems to be
different clashing more aggressive yeah
17 yeah you jumped in the window did you
hear the glass Gordo
Gordon Gekko the test server on you play
was a different game that you could just
download or the same MO succeed test
server on Steam I believe is also kind
of the same thing so our like it's
similar oh you got it it was not charged
that's not good now you have a minute to
protect it here bad noises
okay yeah you just watch that bathroom
windows head to the right man or you
just barricade the bathroom off can't do
that
yeah no more that so you got to be way
more careful now my guess is you don't
definitely don't want to be shot getting
your teammates oh you gotta put another
charge down oh oh oh okay good oh oh why
is he red
Oh is he may be about to blow up I don't
know all right you got someone got
playing a charge right everyone hiding
back again reload is this open beta no
skywalk it's just on the test server
funnel them somewhere else oh good sweet
sweet twelve health and one down
I think it's fine it's fine
can you replace the charge though oh no
no no no it's not fine no no no
definitely not fine
yes I'm explosives you get thrown him or
something I mean I'm not that guy I'm at
the big guy no I just you know check
clearing out the fodder yeah you know
I'm guessing you guys used all your
health care Oh I'm the juggernaut oh you
got some armor from vinca I think should
think of alt durability oh that was a
good that was good that's good that's
good yeah we're playing
ring-around-the-rosy here with our buddy
here the Smasher I think is his name
I'm calling the juggernaut I think
that's good oh you're on your own yeah
oh yeah that was it surprise pandemic a
little more difficult that was a
different scenario though pretty sure so
you know look this is what it looks like
to be on the losing end of it the
infested win yeah yeah well ooh scream
one more oh you did get renowned not
very much for now yeah first simpler
little area man true how often can you
take grenades I think as much as there's
gadgets for what seems like it's like
three unloads it I think we were getting
grenades that often mission lost all
right so it is well it is on a timer
oh it down it's down to one day and
eight minutes so I'm not sure when
they'll reopen but yeah I'm sure if you
follow
gamespot or the Rainbow six siege not
like Twitter or whatnot
you won't probably be able to find out
all right you want to give normal go
or you want pandemic again what is the
chat one well they're gonna tell you to
play pandemic but my gut tells you to
play normal to see more scenarios you
know I mean I guess that's fair right so
you just get a little bit so far we've
seen I think three scenarios but hey
what do I know what indeed let's see
well actually there are videos here or
are those the four maybe each one or
three scenarios so opening there's one
more so no we've seen all three if that
was have we done the nest I know we did
Sierra paradise in the wayans wing so
maybe I mean come on I mean I don't know
just no way answered you decided the
world's your oyster you do you what's
your call normal I don't know I think
normal just because you get to see more
of the map you know that's fair
thank you ethical he's that they said
normal T okay so we played this sorted
on the nest this one was the nest fair
enough so he can win yeah thanks
funky rock I'm not sure how many
scenarios there let me see you say this
article or not so I can't
standard not wild about that
don't just shotgun I did pretty well I
guess wisdom just classify them as
aliens - yeah all right all right
oh no doc oh wow
y'all are can't you switch I guess I
could
time to go doc the shotty go oh okay
okay kind of doc are you I'm not
stealing the shotty we're trying to see
if I can find out how many modes for
that there are so Bob Jones is asking
are they demon aliens from Mars no these
are if you've played sage there's like
contaminant sites throughout the
multiplayer and sort of built into the
situations is an incident at a
university that the toxins are actually
released and this is the toxins have
been released scenario basically seems
like it's three New Mexico resort
hospital in a junkyard
which I think you're in the junkyard
potentially so I believe it's three
someone in check and tell me if I'm
wrong
ethical pixel are you still playing
monster hundred tape I am NOT as much as
I was after I beat it only because right
now it's I'm at end endgame which is
like augmenting and farming you know
gems and stream stones and farming gems
is just I don't know I wish there was a
way to increase my chances I know that
breaking horns and cutting tails and all
that stuff is supposed to do that but
man does it take a while to get some of
those stuff and it's kind of I and
everyone know that knows who me knows
that I like grindy games but I don't
know there's something maybe I have to
switch weapons is what I've been told is
like the next progression and I mean
maybe I'll switch to hammer because the
only stream stone like a rarity eight
weapon stream something I've gotten is
four hammer so maybe that's a sign of
like
I really wish it was dual dual blades
that would been fun but um maybe that's
a sign to try something new maybe it's
hammer time
TTS down low seems to be severely
throttled I'm not sure if that's the
case Kyra because earlier I was able of
Grandda we have pretty good internet
here I was able to get a hundred
download earlier but you know maybe it's
throttled now because everyone knows
that outbreak is actually out so good
yeah you remember this guy I think this
is an easier area to deal with him
though compared to what you're dealing
with in the hospital look at this guy
he's got a dance we sent that guy flying
though I don't know man I feel like
shotgun seems pretty good or at least
maybe having one person with a shotgun
yeah just that the grunts are sort of
overkill
here's paranoid after that pandemic mode
wow you I was like dude are you crazy
you're running into him just ran right
up to him yeah cuz you got shotgun
Oh what's she doing she's hit man did he
did you just assassinate him yeah that's
awesome
all right so that's the thing yeah we
should try that out
maybe she grows some you know cones did
he just kill himself I think he did well
maybe he wanted to do that to max out
his grenades agreed orangy and well
surrender can be unkind yeah I feel like
the more you want something the less it
drops less likely it is to drama
which is like the story of everything by
out I'm like hunter ranked 54 it's
pretty good
probably slowly make my way to 100 but
yeah that's a good segue to tell
everyone here in chat that we do monster
hunter Fridays when we do the when
there's kind of like updates and events
and stuff like that so you should come
back on Friday John Luke and Ben will be
here tomorrow we're gonna play that fun
game called Metal Gear survived I think
so if you're interested in that you
should price one why did come out today
if you're curious at all about Metal
Gear survive and Thursday I'm not sure
yet but Sam will be here and there's a
couple things going on this week I think
there's a battlefield one update
actually as well that has like new maps
new weapons so maybe that on Thursday I
think next Monday I'm gonna play an
anime game I was gonna play it on Friday
yeah anime Monday I guess sword art
online fatal bullet the gun Gale online
arc is out this Friday probably I'll be
able to play Friday so I'll have to play
it Monday but tune in then if you want
to talk anime and watch anime game play
I think the other getting called out for
not healing I was about to say
did you forgot to use his ability huh
you could have just like yes shot a guy
awake or I mean back to life yeah right
in the butt look at this guy tried to
deactivate he's like I don't care about
these guns watch out there's breaches oh
good oh shoot use your ability console
aim not only console aim but I knew
never used our alright we got another
chance he gave you another shot at this
give me another chance that's great
that's what I was open for I did so well
the first time uh-huh do you still have
the thing - oh sweet
Oh oh my god
now it's embarrassing oh sweet Oh have
some black tar dude you're not gonna do
anything to that oh wow here comes doc
we're going for talking afraid big Papa
Doc okay worthwhile sacrifice I hope so
that person's down again you know why I
think that person just likes to melee
kill everything I think that's what's
going on here yeah
who you somehow I don't think meant it
but you dodged that projectile oh okay
you meant to do it my bed stay down
gotta kill it apex down oh he used like
a special ability I think look that way
I'm not sure oh I've heard of it brand
am about the Capcom desire sensor I have
been reading the reddit looking for like
I'm like dude am i farming this wrong am
i doing the wrong thing and then like
everyone's like the desire sensors out
it the game knows that you're not gonna
get what you want are the operators
unlocked and test server I know it's
hard to say not sure because Aaron has
everything right yeah but what a
headline and think oh yeah but he's got
I'm pretty sure he's got season 3 mmm
but they're so they're the reason I
don't think I think the answer is no is
because he did very good
the reason I think the answer is no is
because we did have to unlock the
attachments
I'm guessing it's sort of like still
standard on my system hmm all right
hopefully we barricade before we go in
do though it'll be kind of awkward
though like how many of the operators
that you can choose prone for outbreak
mode are just unlocked like would you
have at least half of those yeah a bunch
of them are vanilla okay got you so is
this basically like zombie Nazis um not
necessarily Jay Allen a little bit but
there's still the they're still layers
of rainbow succeed in here obviously the
abilities you know they're more like
infected alien type things okay so we
yeah we definitely did this we did the
nest so we might have played all three
actually we just didn't get far in the
last one because it was on pandemic well
that's what playing the mode multiple
times that's for you look at you wasting
grenades and always cite one line of
sight yeah that's fair
I'm it's not gonna work out yeah I know
there's an advance that it's not gonna
work out but I'm just saying whoa dang
shotgun black black oh here we go
I like how I took him a couple hits till
I kind of like break two boards and
thinking just breaks all of it in one go
whatever exactly
yeah they look like they're mainly
downstairs a bunch oh good night um so
you can just knife knife them yeah I
feel like the I think it's the weak spot
that you might have the knife I don't
know
because you weren't gun fighting them
earlier - yeah or it's like a last hit
kind of thing we can do this all day now
yeah I understand load wise they're
kinda similar I don't know if they have
like protect and slash escort the people
though and zombies do they this is like
a bad scene Oh God
yeah come put that guy you're surrounded
fortunately I can self revive that's
great
oh god I'm trapped in here I'm like why
are you why are you still gun fighting
man you crazy they all around you you up
oh sorry you can
boo barbed wire 420 and blow nishan how
would you like a fine apparently
apparently they don't really come from
upstairs oh you got more health upstairs
oh yeah feel like we're going faster oh
so this is the junkyard map oh yeah oh
the last time you only had two people I
think that is why it took so long yeah
that's true I thought cool pixel uh we
will be reviewing Metal Gear survive we
didn't get the game early I think was
timorous on it so probably the hope is
maybe end of the week but I can't I
don't know the scope of the game so hard
for me to say if you'll actually be done
so you can stay tuned I'm sure it'll be
out when it's out
yeah they yeah the escort thing was
interesting because like we had a big
smasher chasing us and he had to kind of
like you were littering away the Smasher
so that he could get the escort to like
the next destination and then we got
dropped because we had poor internet but
that's because our we're using like a
workaround because a corporate Internet
doesn't play well with you play which is
unfortunate but we are working on a
permanent solution for that and
hopefully they come in 1:32 it will be
all good
activate the green
you got hostile hold position until the
crane clears your back don't leave any
no remember was this the last part of it
I think was there's one more like little
part after yeah thanks oh whoa where's
gasps that guy doesn't know is it smoke
yeah
what 20 is Metal Gear survives actually
coming out to and a lot of discussion
so the reminds me of Metal Gear survive
slightly different obviously but uh
you're kind of building a fort to stop
infected like aliens from getting into
your fortification like one of them is
like protect the drill and it's like
kind of like in this zone except it's
like third-person I mean and you can
build traps and stuff like that I guess
that's the difference to brand em says
I'll try this question one last time
before going back to lurking and working
is it you all base game operators will
be also unlock for the standard addition
above with this patch do you know that
I'm not sure let me take a look brand
name because it be the operation come
here right yeah
need bullets let's see you need more
bullets oh no yes apparently rainbow
succeed six will be giving a number of
operators away for free soon starting
with the new season of DLC on March 3rd
all versions of the game except for the
started edition will include all 20 base
operators for no extra charge in
addition all past and future weapon
attachments will now be unlocked from
the get-go and the game started Edition
will now include six operators rather
than four as the case was before so
hopefully that answered your question
Thank You Oscar for having that article
for me to conveniently look up
I don't think he's looking behind them
Aaron's on the case you must be watching
the stream because the answer to the
operator's question and slack for me
well yeah I just read it you're just
delayed yeah okay so there's one more
and this must be where you defended the
three charges alpha Bravo and Charlie
wonder if you get like more for
defending all three let's go dude hell
yeah so the random awesome go back to
lurking jump to the window I got it
ruin a perfect barricade early now you
got to rebuild that barricade it takes
Oh get the one upstairs maybe or unless
that person's getting the one upstairs
[Music]
oh maybe don't plant the last one so
that you guys can barricade first yeah
my bad
I just wanted this is this is where they
were a problem last time
what's up Kahn wow I can't colonel last
name sorry probably butchered that yeah
you have no names so oh I should get
those yeah I should get this get
probably get those before it you
barricade it off maybe oh good idea or
this person gonna take all the
barricades or gun camp
that's why wait so much for that plan
yeah you need to get through the greens
anyways it's kind of fun after this
mission can we perhaps see what options
recruit has an outbreak that's Brandon
Oh was it recruit on there yeah
first the top left take I think yeah we
can we can check that out Brandon it's
gonna say we might be wrapping up soon
but we can try to check that out it's
like one last thing but that would kind
of suck because then we leave our
teammates behind so maybe we'll play one
more I guess as the recruit it makes
sense right to not plant all of them oh
it has to now you have to like you won't
trigger the scenario until you guys plan
so I would assume by now you guys should
be fine because you've done your
fortification so I don't know I think
they just don't they just attack it
regardless or they probably just go to
where it is is this out on console no
crayfish it will be out on console March
the six only on the test server is
currently which is on PC we're gonna do
you're gonna help them out I'm gonna
stay up top I mean last time you guys
ended up barely surviving with one
charge I think the good news is your
dock like special ability you got three
shots to bring people back to life
man I worked really hard on this worth
that's what you can build so quickly and
like the regular game that takes a lot
longer
not today sir and bear kid and he was
deterred I think you should just stay
I want to say it was one of those apex
is at the end of this part we got two
people Oh got the barbed wired get
rooted no man you're fine you might be
getting barbed wire again okay see ya
ah
tickled them yeah Jack wall is open
that's what's going on yeah what it
attacking it and I'm running a time this
is a problem
well maybe aim better okay I'm the
Internet get good yeah you got barbed
wire by the way yeah
Oh kilos inbound you're good ooh get
stabbed Oh what you got clear the
hostiles you're not done yet
yeah I know and that person's down
they're both down oh okay Ryan it's all
on you I call a choke here I'm calling
for a choke I can't get out of the dang
oh I called it you're supposed to be
able to overcome that Oh Ryan I said
when I started I am NOT that's true but
still all right another death screen a
different one damn I got killed a lot
Beaufort retry I'll see to ten we're
getting to then imagine if you want
imagine if you won there hmm went 300
just so you know mm-hmm all right once
you check out recruit and then we'll
call it a call it a thing after that
doctor fun how can I get it test servers
on you play or strea stream steam as a
separate kind of like game so download
rainbow succeed test server and that's
how you would get it right now for
another day it looks like and then we'll
see when they bring it back but it looks
like it's out for a day
all right we're checking out the hotel
now Sierra paradise part 1 ok I fixed my
internet says probs Tokai be ok so I
mean actually it's oh you got a lot of
scene there looks like a lot of just
standard
yeah I mean you know I don't think you
have to necessarily play as a recruit
it's up to you sick sounds good props
we're not gonna talk to you though and
we're probably meet you what are you
gonna play is the one that you want is
it was lying again had the but hopefully
one of them picks doc though I think
you're right I think a doc okay
I think doc because he can sell for us
and res your teammates it quicker like I
feel like you have that definitely have
to have I'm probably in the harder mode
but you know it's it's yeah it
definitely does seem like they made doc
really necessary
later goob oh and we already had a
dropout in sweet
oh really so this won't take long
well that one guy did say he was having
internet problems so there was that
just use to me yeah all right this is
just he must be like friends with the
other guy it's my guess all right well
good luck to you maybe you can hold this
point by yourself unlike last time I
have faith in you
I was just waiting to see if it was
gonna explode blow up on its own dang if
I first didn't look like a normal person
nailed it yeah oh you know they've got
some good like sound work going on oh
yeah it's actually perfect timing that
you're by yourself because I have to
leave that one it's okay at the cloth
yeah
worst cases we'll just have to call it I
don't think I'm gonna make it that far
no it's fine oh so this is not in the
bedroom so it's it seems like that
locale can change right yeah totally
Oh behind ya hey this guy just doesn't
care about the furniture seriously
where's the consideration so there's
like people screaming
Oh Oh God no this isn't well if you kill
that guy he'll blow them all up and get
the wombocombo going and they gonna like
stop coming like you actually come
through that wall yeah probably not
since I wasted all my barricades on it
yeah that's the rule your PC is a very
big potato some yeah it's actually a
pretty big potato it's pretty big
actually paying the butt to carry around
all right good luck sir I actually hope
you die because highly unnecessary
refilled filth all right yeah our two
teammates dipped out on us and if it
works the way it does and the other kind
of Moses you had been mentioning they
don't really rematch make so it is what
it is
to do it now yes no thinking less
thinking more doing oh oh there's more
there's more so it's five purse wing it
appears and that's like 30 damage
remember when you healed up I guess
you're just gonna have to heal it but
you have to do it again yeah yeah use
these but I mean like you're by yourself
so you have more heals but then if you
get overrun you get over in right all
right here we go wish Ryan don't forget
you got in that pack later
I'll tell you how bad this is gonna get
for you yeah pretty bad so this is the
other things that this guy's got a
50-round get stunned well the thing is
at least you don't well I'm not positive
on this but earlier you didn't lose
until you died because you can replant
so I think as long as you replant it
you're fine it's getting a lot more
tactical when he's by himself apparently
damn low slow reload slow reload on that
50 round mag fun deer right
please tell me this is an infinite spawn
so it isn't there's only so many of them
usually by the time you know that
objective there goes off you might have
to clear the remaining monsters to kind
of proceed to the next part but yeah
even if they destroy it as mentioned you
can kind of go back and replant usually
you have two other operators with you as
teammates but I think one of them was
having connection problems so the and
there were friends so then they just
dipped out together they might just have
the same Ubisoft problem that we have
here in the office so sometimes our
corporate internet doesn't like yeah I
know there's some type of firewall thing
going on there so like well Buddhist
like we got booted from one game earlier
but we've made it through a couple games
actually we've only made it through one
game now that I think about it we won
our first match and we lost everything
after that I think yeah
we're gonna yeah they're gonna take that
again
so far kind of so good some of that it
was almost done - Oh was it where you
almost at zero I mean this is no parkour
from our spotty dude and he decided to
sacrifice his life to blow up that
barricade it's not a fan of barricades
that guy try it again meaning good game
not the other GG yeah only four seconds
can Ryan do it I think the short answer
is no really I think you'll make it
there and then I'll call it a shame so
there's that I think go I think you'll
make plenty for starting to get more
good job no you're fine as long as it
stays as these guys and you don't get
any other nasty stuff
no they got it again this really is not
a one player game okay yeah I'm sure
it's doable though gotta be oh yeah I'm
sure maybe helped up then replant
thanks good no that's like
I assume that means there's an apex
around them yeah that's sweet
oh yeah the dream is the dream is dead
it's dead no no not yet yes oh good I
don't think the dream is dead quite yet
oh it's so dead it's extremely dead yeah
well let's see yeah yeah everyone's got
a different uh killcam yeah there we go
oh and he summons guys that's pretty
good
oh he's got tentacles for legs no that's
cool so now we just got a die do like
the two other that's pretty cool
actually I like that I like that we got
to do a compilation a death compilation
you could kill cams yeah anyways thank
you guys all for tuning in Thank You
Ryan for playing that was a Rainbow six
siege is new outbreak moments on the
test servers for free right now if you
have PC you can download that from you
play or steam looks like there's about
23 hours and 30 minutes left
I'm sure they'll bring it back again but
it'll be kind of intermittently here and
there so stay tuned GameSpot of course
to find out more information on win its
you know how long it's going for or you
know if it goes down and comes back up
chimeras also out operation chimera so
if you want to test that out those
operators are in and I think some of the
changes are in people are already
complaining well blitz cuz he's
apparently he is a little buggy right
now Ubisoft has already come out and
said there's like his speed something's
going on there that's not supposed to
happen so don't just I mean if you're
gonna complain about it or talk about it
just put it in you know send in a ticket
and things like that as they want you to
so that they can fix their game but um
anything else no I mean I check it out
it's I think it's pretty cool it's has
that kind of style to it and then the
new operators are trying to cool too I
mean they're two attackers so you're
gonna see like two of them every time
you play anything multiplayer but yeah
so you hop on for that if not it comes
out officially March the 6th so you can
check that out so till next
time when we're live tomorrow with most
likely metal gear survives and more as
alien zombie time something killin yeah
one watch stairs we're gonna kill more
monsters later bye
[Music]